und dass athen ist uns der
bundesinnenminister zugeschaltet guten
abend herr seehofer guten vorschlag
kommt
sie konnten sich jetzt selbst ein bild
davon machen wie überfordert
griechenland mit der situation ist und
ja auch um hilfe bittet während in
deutschland gegebenenfalls bereiten
flüchtlinge von den griechischen inseln
aufzunehmen um in dieser notsituation zu
helfen
zunächst ist es zutreffen dass sowohl in
der türkei als auch wie griechenland die
zahl der zuwanderer enorm zugenommen hat
in den letzten monaten in griechenland
hat sich die zahl der zuwanderer
verdoppelt nun ist es meine feste
überzeugung dass man in solchen
situationen die länder an den
außengrenzen der eu nicht alleine lassen
darf und deshalb habe ich diese reise
gemacht gemeinsam mit der europäischen
kommission um zu überlegen wie wir
diesen ländern helfen können
denn wenn wir ihnen nicht helfen das
möchte ich der bevölkerung in
deutschland sagen dann ist es nur eine
frage der zeit bis waren diese
flüchtlinge auch in deutschland sind wie
helfen wir denn dann konkret
griechenland also zum beispiel mit der
aufnahme von flüchtlingen sie hatten das
ja bei den italienern bei den in seenot
geratenen flüchtlingen die auf malta und
in italien landen gesagt wir nehmen ein
viertel auf wäre das nicht auch ein
angebot an griechenland athen sehr dass
sicherlich gerne ja es sind ja immer
lösungen für die europäische union
insgesamt die bundesrepublik deutschland
kann nicht alleine
all diese
problematiken selbst lösen oder gar
flüchtlinge aus allen herren länder
aufnehmen
aber wir sind uns einig heute in
griechenland gewesen dass wir dringend
eine europäische lösung brauchen wo sich
möglichst viele europäische länder
beteiligen um flüchtlinge aus
griechenland aufzunehmen
das ganze 60 slomka ist nein denn das
können wir nur mit den mitgliedstaaten
der europäischen union gemeinsam lösen
wir treffen uns ja als innenminister
nächste woche in luxemburg und
anschließend treffen sich die
regierungschefs
das ist keine sache die man jetzt in
wenigen stunden auflösen kann und in dem
zusammenhang ist noch ganz wichtig
typisch das bestehende abkommen zwischen
der türkei und der europäischen union
das besagt dass legale oder illegale
zuwanderer aus der türkei die in
griechenland landen von griechenland
wieder zurück überstellt werden in die
türkei als übergangs zu verhindern
da gibt es ja bislang den letzten drei
jahren ja das stimmt das haben die
türken auch moniert das habe ich gerade
dem griechischen ministerpräsidenten
mitgeteilt dass dies ein hauptanliegen
der türken ist stellt uns doch über
stellt uns doch die migranten wieder
zurück in die türkei
der sinn des abkommens ist das dann
nicht weitere flüchtlinge in die türkei
kommen weil sie wissen sie werden wieder
zurück über stellt von griechenland und
das muss sich verbessern und da können
wir zum beispiel hilfen beim grenzschutz
bei denen verfahren die dadurch geführt
werden müssen
also es gibt schon möglichkeit dass wir
auch bilateral helfen können und das
habe ich sowohl den türken als auch den
griechen zugesagt und das sage ich noch
mal das ist in unserem interesse
wenn nämlich die türken und die griechen
mit dem problem alleine nicht fertig
werden
dann wandern die menschen weiter das
haben wir in der vergangenheit erlebt
und deshalb müssen wir deutsche ein
großes interesse haben dass
ist eine europäische lösung gibt und ich
glaube da ist jetzt ein frischer schwung
erfahrung müssen das abkommen mit der
türkei in der form überhaupt noch zu
retten haben sie zu sagen oder
versprechungen
die türkische regierung gemacht
präsident erdogan hat ja damit gedroht
die tore aufzumachen wenn er nicht mehr
unterstützung bekommt ja aber die die
die atmosphäre unsere gespräche mit dem
innenminister mit dem vize präsidenten
mit dem außenminister waren wir in einer
sehr sehr guten atmosphäre ich weiß dass
sagen politiker oft aber darauf ist
jetzt wirklich zu und wir sehen wo es
für uns kein ass fähre oder ja natürlich
reichen schöne atmosphäre und gute worte
alleine nicht deshalb haben wir ja sehr
intensiv diskutiert zum beispiel beim
vollzug dieser europäische türkischen
erklärung dass die wieder mit leben
erfüllt wird das glaube ich hat jetzt
dieser besuch bewirkt und jetzt müssen
wir nacharbeiten dass auch die
europäische union sich hiermit ein
klingt und in den nachhaltige lösungen
hinbekommt als angela merkel das
flüchtlings abkommen mit der türkei
ausgehandelt hatte haben sie davor
gewarnt ist scharf kritisiert inzwischen
sind sie aber der ansicht dass es sich
doch lohnt dieses abkommen
aufrechtzuerhalten oder ja bei mir ist
offensichtlich immer notwendig dass man
feststellt dass ich meine meinung
geändert hätten sage ja gut aber damit
muss man leben als politiker ist trifft
einfach nicht zu ich habe immer gesagt
die schließung der balkanroute durch
mazedonien und österreich war damals ein
erster großer erfolg
und dieses abkommen zwischen türkei und
die eu das war ein großer erfolg der
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
und da verdanken wir auch diese dieser
erklärung dass es sozusagen nicht einen
nachschub gibt aus der türkei das hat ja
funktioniert
jetzt hat die flüchtlingszahl zugenommen
ich darf einmal darauf hinweisen dass in
der türkei 5 millionen flüchtlinge leben
sie eher eine niedrig gegriffen die zahl
und drei millionen stehen vor der tür
das heißt insgesamt acht millionen der
hat seinen unheimlichen zusätzlichen
schub gegeben und da können wir die
türkei mit dieser problematik nicht
allein gelassen und wer in deutschland
glaubt wir dürfen damit der türkei nicht
versuchen das problem in den griff zu
bekommen
ich habe jetzt gehört ich hätte vor dem
erdogan einen kniefall gemacht es ist
wirklich unzutreffend wenn wir nicht
helfen sind diese menschen früher oder
später überall in europa und vor allem
auch in deutschland sagt aber dass
innenminister herr seehofer ich danke
für das gespräch